l'information du jour au niveau local
elle nous vient de poissy la commune a
inauguré à cet après midi son centre de
vaccination contre le coc vie de 19
c'est le premier en france hors hôpitaux
est nommé chez maurice est en référence
à la première personne vaccinée en
france il est installé dans le bâtiment
du centre de diffusion artistique de la
ville
ce site avait déjà été transformé lors
du premier confinement en un lieu de
consultation puis de dépistage le centre
de vaccination s'adresse dans un premier
temps aux soignants pompiers et aides à
domicile de plus de 50 ans sur rendez
vous les inscriptions se font notamment
via d'octo libre écoutez le maire de
poissy interrogé par justine brasil
comment on va gérer les doses de la
veille pour le lendemain on sait que le
jour j on a 150 personnes à vacciner 150
divisé par cinq
on a le nombre de doses à aller chercher
à versailles à l'hôpital de versailles
pourquoi parce que c'est le centre pivot
départementale qui lui va le cas échéant
acheminé à l'hôpital de poissy et nous
nous allons aller avec un camion
frigorifique de la ville de poissy
chercher ces doses vous arrivez ici vous
êtes enregistré consultation pré
vaccinale vaccination enregistrement des
données une demi-heure d'attendre pour
voir s'il n'y a pas d'effets secondaires
et puis vous ressortez tranquillement et
le centre sera également ouvert d'ici la
fin janvier aux personnes âgées de plus
de 75 ans